Mass Effect Andromeda new cinematic
trailer launch yesterday november
seventh or n7 day if you're one of those
people or work by our people yeah that's
too hot so you and jean-luc did a
trailer breakdown what it's telling us
about Andromeda you know this games been
too late a bunch a lot of people have
left the studio we saw III things III
this kind of a letdown of drought yeah
it wasn't it wasn't game player just
weird like some of the audio wasn't even
synced up with character the whole face
is talking like it didn't seem like it
was synced talking about the one that
you three why yesterday thought would a
3-1 okay um yesterday was pretty cool it
was writers dad like a parent Alec
writer I like writer yeah so he's in it
this time if it wins the main character
try turning yes you can pick between
male or female like which is typical of
mass effect but then what's different in
this is that if you pick the male and
the female character is still gonna be
in the game she's gonna be sort of your
wingman wing woman okay cooing wing
person wing person so I want to talk
today mainly about like with trailer and
then uh Mac Walters the creative
director at Bioware was answering a lot
of questions on Twitter yesterday about
how this game is going to play between
like the romances and the overall like
genre it's gonna fall into that's the
one thing I wanna touch on first if you
don't see the cinematic trailer again is
just talking about how about the
Andromeda initiative like the 600 year
trip that they put people into
cryostasis for like a bunch of different
species to send to the Andromeda galaxy
which is a close neighbor class and the
grants give me things but again it would
take like 600 years to get there
according to Mass Effect lower based on
the technology they have but it also
takes place between mass effect 2 and 3
so that's Bioware's way of avoiding the
consequences of the ending of 3 so by
the time you arrive Nia drama galaxy in
Mass Effect Andromeda the events of
three have already taken place it's long
after three it's also like so far away
that probably wouldn't matter I'll the
Reapers universal or they just each
galaxy uh getting too i'm not i'm not
entirely sure i'm sure if i had done
some one yeah have you know as i could
figure out but i don't think the Reapers
are gonna be in this game i know there's
some things in that trail that kind of
look like reaper tech yeah but i really
don't think so i think
trying to move on and yeah and doubt it
it'd be cool to see Reaper tacky I don't
want them figuring into the narrative
too heavily again because I feel like
that has come and gone and you pretty
much have done everything possible the
Reapers yes we've dealt with that let's
not deal with that again yeah so but
okay so you were the one that brought
this up to me you said it's going to be
more RPG ish than two and three because
the first mass effect felt much more
like an RPG with its abilities and its
character ranking but also just it
didn't like two and three lean really
heavily into the cover shooting and kind
of simplified the RPG aspects but this
one Mac Walters creative director and
Twitter was saying this is going to be
have more RPG elements can you I'll talk
about that yes so I mean it's kind of
been rumored before that they were gonna
go back to their roots with this but it
seems like from what I've heard and what
I've seen it sounds like this is going
to be very heavy RPG and still kind of
keep that uh intense action like
third-person cover-based shooting and
try to figure out more of a blend
between those two which i think is what
people want they want that exploration
they want that customization the RPG
elements of leveling up but I think they
still want that pretty solid
third-person shooting intact as well
yeah in terms of like building
relationship with your characters they
also have loyalty missions are back from
mass effect 2 was that mass effect 2
you're building up the loyalties for you
to character so then by the time the
suicide mission rolls around they have a
higher chance of survival from I
understand yeah I don't know how those a
factor into this obviously I'm not sure
you would either but are you happy about
that that you like those in mass effect
2 yeah i thought the loyalty missions
were some of the best things about mass
effect just getting to know some of
those characters were great in it from
what we've seen it seems like there's
gonna be a cool cast of characters that
you'll be able to get to know and it'll
be nice least i think it'll be nice
doing some of these missions without the
threat of galactic destruction over it
cuz i mean like some of these missions
were like help me find my sister
something like that which is cool but at
the same time it's like we're trying to
save a galaxy here yeah who cares why
your sister she's probably dead that's
what i would always think no one did you
callous but right now like you said I'm
worried about like billions of billions
of people not yeah Susan that is doing
what I really
they find the balance of this game at
least in terms of story I hope they kind
of like figure out a way to like
basically not put a clock on this story
that's at least to stringent sure if
that makes sense because I do want it to
like take time and build and explore
characters and universes and fun stuff
that's always a difficult balance to
strike with open world games i know with
mafia 3 hangar 13 was saying they really
wanted to make each of your missions
feel urgent so you're not going to stop
and play darts or go on a date like you
wouldn't grant the thought of five
although in grand theft auto 5 that
storyline kind of allows for that more
you're not trying to bring down a mob as
a revenge tale at least in Grand Theft
Auto 5 yeah but I mean it's also might
have been just hangar 13s reason for
justifying not putting a lot of minor
things in the game I don't know I want
don't want to have I'm aspect or ma
mafia 3 too much but PG play the bass
affect games at all like why quite you
should know the answer this question
it's always no right you don't like
video games no it's getting but are you
sending Andromeda pass just like the
hype surrounding it uh uh you know so
Mass Effect one is a game that I was
super curious about that and I was
definitely ready to like jump into that
game circumstances didn't allow to it
allow for it and then two and three lost
at RPG bend a little bit so given that
it might be going back to what happened
in 1 i'm totally sold i feel kind of
fortunate that I'm not wrapped up in the
storyline because it seems like three
faced a lot of sort of like controversy
yeah i don't want that baggage so i'm
looking forward to playing a drama de
almost as someone who just is new to the
series I think that's part of the reason
why they positioned this story to start
kind of in-between sure but um also I
think it was Mac Walters again who said
that you don't really need to have
played the other ones in order to get
into this story and appreciate it which
developers always say when they come out
with like a fourth game like all gears
of war for you and play the other ones
and yeah here's more for and its defense
did a good job of that like stripping
you that prologue so to give you like a
hint of the COG Wars or the pendulum
Wars whatever before you get into it and
the original trilogy but yeah Mass
Effect Andromeda the whole thing that
strikes me is your pathfinder that's
what it's called now that's like your
group I guess but you're almost like a
ranger kind of right like in
investigating the Andromeda galaxy and
just it's kind of a sci-fi trope now
trying to find new places for humans to
inhabit but
assume that's the Andromeda initiative
is right yeah so the Andromeda
initiative at least based on the other
TRO they released there's four ships I
said three in the trailer breakdown
there's actually four each one kind of
is run by a different race presumably
like the four council races I won't get
too into that and each one is led by a
Pathfinder in that Pathfinder they say
is like someone who's good with combat
good with exploration and like you know
is a good guide and then a scientist
that kind of hints that there's going to
be combatted me exploration and there's
going to be like sort of researching
different materials playing a character
that would be fun to play as in a video
game yeah yeah exactly works out or you
could be like I feel like gonna run into
matt damon your son of these planets
he's been there for a while I hope so it
could be two movies and referencing but
I'm not gonna say sighs I just spoiled
something um yeah no I mean it striking
is like I don't know like interstellar
kind of that whole like the whole
distance from the Milky Way the whole
you know like the time it takes to
travel there I imagine that could lead
to some cool like storytelling moments
like I like if we're gonna relay
information back to the Milky Way
they're not gonna get it for however
long you know like depending on because
the mass relays from the first trilogy
which allow like the travel between
stars are in those you know star
clusters and solar systems don't go to
the Andromeda galaxy and that's what I
had to send these ships that took 600
years to get there in cryostasis you
wake up you know you're done presumably
is still the same age I don't know I've
never been frozen like that no no what
does it feel that you're born like 400
years ago you just down now yeah is that
my what my personality conveys yeah do I
have like a wisdom about me no that's
exactly what I'm going for and I'm not
hitting it nah really know you could
definitely be a wizard Pete just because
of my glasses no your beard in your
glasses it yeah but yeah anyway and then
they said like same thing with romances
you can romance aliens same-sex romances
are back you can kiss a bunch of people
which i guess is always fun muches
people care a lot more about the
relationships the romances in these
games and I do this is one of these
kissing games yeah it's a dating
simulator where you have to travel the
every potential mate in the Milky Way is
gone so yet to go to in drama
see and bone exactly yep whatever alien
species you want if you've got game so
yeah you're skilled in science combat
probably biotics yeah I love making
flirting bring a sick pick-up line with
you them drama two galaxies it might
come in handy what would your pick up
line I just saw Becky in for Bioware
well my pickup line me we're pretty far
from the Sun but still feels pretty hot
right now come on off the cuff that was
bad yeah but off the cuff man you're
gonna have to lay ahead dude I've guts I
don't I didn't have 600 years to prepare
for that alright with you before I play
the game and then i'll i'll use it on
some asari that is attracting me oh
sorry is a re oh right the blue ones
yeah yeah with like snake down go ahead
tentacle ponytails yeah I mean like
you're approving smell yeah yeah I'd
better bring a pickup line alright this
is um where did we lose traxxas
conversation I don't know anything else
like that the trailer showed you i mean
like obviously it's on games i right now
you can go to watch this Mass Effect
Andromeda cinematic trailer breakdown
that Jake and John Luke did but anything
that you guys pulled out of that that
you want to talk about in terms of what
it might tell us about and drama that I
didn't ask you um some things actually
to be honest I think more information
came from that other trailer that they
showed the kind of like Andromeda
initiative trailer they just showed they
showed some weapons some returning
weapons some newer weapons they showed
sort of a or they hinted at sort of a
colonization aspect or you able to
create like colonies I don't know how in
depth that is they haven't talked about
that at all but that could be something
fascinating it kind of makes sense right
if you're colonizing a new a new planet
or whatever you're going to want to
create buildings structures things of
that nature sure um two to four player
co-op still oh yeah how that's gonna
work like a separate mode maybe like
mass effect 3 I would assume the
multiplayer the several modes would be
the safe bet I at least I hope I think
it's gonna be sort of similar to I guess
maybe destiny we're like most year well
no because you can play call through all
the missions on destiny right but yeah I
think there's going to be like so
of a campaign but on your map or
whatever you can pick like okay here's a
here's a four player co-op mission that
I can do I think it'll be similar to
Mass Effect 3 but will be more seamless
once again speculation I don't know yeah
but I think that would be a cool way to
do co-op for that game cool yeah I'm
excited for it like games been delayed
so much and people have left by aware
that have working on it I don't know
what's going on over there we didn't
interview with aaron flynn the studio
director studio manager back at e3 which
is really interesting you should go
check that out it's also on gamespot but
yeah in the meantime I guess we'll keep
an eye out for more coming from I don't
know they're gonna be doing maybe
another trailer with a Mass Effect
Andromeda initiative yes so the they're
supposed to give new initiative
information like David said when but
it's gonna be kind of often and the
gameplay reveal is it the video game
awards which I don't know the date on
that it's usually in december though
it's early December in early December so
not long until you see more of a mass
effect cool so yeah that is Mass Effect
Andromeda the new cinematic trailer in
the Andromeda initiative trailer which
jake and John Luke detail extensively in
a video breakdown on gamespot so go
check that out and let us know you think
in the comments below
you